Let's return to our scatter plot that summarized the relationship between
age and mean friend count. Recall that we ended up creating this
plot from the new data frame that we created using the
d ply r package. The plot looked like this. As you can
see, the black line has a lot of random noise to
it. That is, the mean friend count rises and falls over each
age. Let's print out some of our data frame to have
a closer look. As we can see, the mean friend count increases,
then decreases later. In one particular case, we can see
that for 30 year olds, the mean friend count is
actually lower compared to the 29 year olds and the
31 year olds. Now some year to year discontinuities might make
sense, such as the spike at age 69. But others
are likely just to be noise around the true smoother
relationship between age and friend count. That is, they reflect
that we just have a sample from the data generating process.
And so the estimated mean friend count for each age
is the true mean plus some noise. We can imagine
that the noise for this plot would be worse if
we chose finer bins for age. For example, we could estimate
conditional means for each age, measured in months instead of
years. Over the next few programming exercises, you're going to
do just that. You're going to create a plot just like
this one with a new variable that measures ages in months
instead of years. Then you'll plot the conditional mean for
ages in months, and we'll compare this graph to the
one that you create. To start, you're going to create
the age with months variable, and save it into the data
frame. This variable will have each user's age measured in
months rather than in years. So, if a user is 36
years old and was born in March, the user's age
would be 36.75. Try coding this up in R for yourself.
And then once you have the code, copy and
paste it into the browser and submit. Now, this is
one of the exercises where the grader will automatically
check your output. Don't worry if you don't get this
one right on your first try. It's pretty tough.
I really recommend thinking about ages and people being born
in different months. How would that affect the variable age
with months? Working with actual values might help you here.